I always tried to add humor to anything
that I do one early morning the company
was in formation waiting for the Cadre
to join us on that day I was the student
company Commander while we were waiting
I shouted out a command that anyone who
that can't Tamp down Tamp tap dance must
be a well the entire company
started tap dancing in place all of a
sudden they all stopped I had my back to
the Cadre building and it was at that
time that I realized I was the only one
still tap dancing I stopped and slowly
turned around and stood there and there
stood the Cadre they did have a sense of
humor and got a chuckle out of it but
they told me to drop and start doing
push-ups and here you have one of your
first life lessons in this book life
lesson one add humor it really helps
when things are getting tough sometimes
it's not easy to find it within you but
even the pows somehow found a way to
pass some slivers of humor through the
cracks in the Prison Walls the soul
needs it make sure you contribute some
for the benefit of the people around you